good day I'm Alana Pierce and this
podcast and every other podcast that I
make is brought to you by our supporters
on patreon patreon actually got the
entire last episode of the show which
was not posted publicly due to a couple
of audio issues in an edit free versions
of this episode if you enjoy the show
just edit free bro and edit free he'll
read anything you
say and an idiot free version of this
episode if you enjoy en the show
consider supporting at the link in the
description see it how do you say
goodbye in Australia um you can't say
good day I don't know that there is a
good um all right
T anyway usually we intro the show and
we have guest hi everyone I'm an that's
Austin this is Rahul and that's Andy
over
there uh my angle go I'm pretty sure you
pointed into rahul's lap and said that
Austin that's Austin I'm gonna take it
I'm gonna go with it that's Austin right
there hey how you doing I'm in my happy
place uh we asked Rahul and Andy to come
on playwatch listen today uh because the
strikes are over we're allowed to talk
about a little show they both worked on
called The Fall of the House of user
which came out a month ago October 12th
it's been a minute yeah to talk it rul
plays Napoleon Usher Andy along with his
fellow composer make up the two Newton
Brothers was the composer on the show
I'm actually the third Newton brother
now oh yeah with with the Newton
Brothers is now yeah yeah we're hit the
road yeah I do I rap over them music and
then Mike cuts it all out so it just
becomes it goes back to being just a
score well you get it in there
eventually yeah one day
um Austin I I like that you had to one
up it I like how you had to one up it to
triplets it's not Brothers you you're
just going to let us simmer on that one
the new trips born within born within
minutes of each other and you know very
obviously so well Andy aren you like
actually not even
Brothers yeah we're not even Brothers
yeah where did Newton Brothers come from
we just we made it up because we had
like separate jobs like a long time ago
when we started this we had separate
jobs to actually pay for our gear
because we weren't getting paid enough
to make a living and the people we were
working for didn't want to know we were
working on other things so we were like
let's come up with a name that has
nothing to do with who we are um and we
came up with the Newton brothers and
then we just honestly were just too lazy
to have changed it so we just kept it uh
but Taylor what's Taylor's name full
name Taylor new Taylor so Taylor's
middle name is Newton yeah so that was
right he had like a list of all these
names like one of of our ideas was like
we had these techy name ideas and we
were like ah we don't want to be like
too ridiculous and we were like this is
pretty like right in the middle of the
road like you know we could score Fight
Club 2 or Legends of the Fall 2 you
know which are actually both uh both
featuring Brad Pit in a very uh uh
similar role yeah exactly that's a good
what's your Newton brother I feel like
you you just go by Austin winry boring
I know it's pretty bad I uh I like I
like the in intrinsically confusing
nature of the moniker of Newton Brothers
I feel like there's only one other
there's like Tom and Andy um which I'm
pretty sure are not named Tom and Andy
um what is that like another composing
je it's like yeah they they were pretty
big maybe 20 to 20 through 10 years I
imagine they're still around I don't
even know who they are as far as I know
it's not even two people um um but it's
like a credited a lot of horror films uh
oh um that um Andy are you familiar with
Tom and Andy yeah I actually yeah it
there is a Tom and an Andy and it was
actually uh to your point Austin it is
really great marketing because like they
had the whole thing it's like Tom and
Andy is all like one word uh yeah
there's no spaces it's like that game
company yeah yeah yeah and it's kind of
like uh don't really know you know
what's going on in a good way it's it's
it's it's good it works it's a very rare
composer Partnerships are generally
fairly rare um and yeah why how did you
become Z and uh KN Newton Howard did
begins yeah James Newton Howard James
Newton Howard yeah yeah I love that they
both know that it's oh I would never but
they're not they're they're like buddies
that thought it'd be fun to work
together that's not that's different
common I mean I Austin probably has a
good I mean I would say from being in it
for a while it's tricky because things
get like really at a certain point you
have to make decisions like creative
decisions and if you're not if you're
not Jing with the other person a
thousand per which in life are we ever
driving with anyone a th% no and it gets
tricky so it's it's constant sort of uh
dialogue and discussing you know from
the the most basic thing of like there's
a main title piece of music and
sometimes there's five pieces of music
or two pieces of music or sometimes it's
just one and you just land it but then
you get into the discussion of like
which one are you know which one is the
one to present or we GNA present all
five or um and Taylor and I have kind of
used the the good part of it for like
present ations right for like first
playbacks I I sort of feel like I don't
know he does like no one really knows it
first you have an idea I think and so
we'll present like lots of ideas that
are often different sometimes I'll
disagree with Taylor and he'll disagree
with me but we'll just say like you know
what let's let's play it for Mike and
let Mike decide what what like he and
Trevor think in this case um and I and
sometimes that just sort of works its
its way out I don't know what do you
what do you think Austin because I know
you've you've collaborated with a bunch
of people I have but it's always
been like a
situation
where the powers that be have kind of
independently hired me and someone else
like it's it's far more common in games
than in film because I think there's a
lot of perception of it's just too big
for one person to do which I don't think
is actually a correct judgment but it is
often that's the justification or or
there have been situations where they go
this
person writes great Melodies but this
person does cool weird creepy textures
so and we want both and of course they
underestimate that probably both people
can do both but it is often the like
I've definitely been hired before where
it was you know you're the that you're
the guy to do this and you're the guy to
do that and then of course as soon as
you get your hands dirty everybody's
doing everything so the whole premise of
it it was kind of dumb to be honest it's
probably marketing occasionally like I
know I'm pretty sure Detroit become
human had multiple composers because
there were multiple characters you
played as and they were trying to like
separate the composers based on
character and I would guess that's a
marketing Ploy because it sounds I don't
yeah maybe maybe that helps justify it I
think it was more the idea of that they
just really wanted them to be
sufficiently distinct and also sometimes
it's depending on the production
especially in a game like that it's also
that there's almost like parallel
Productions that almost are not even in
true in work like for example the guy
that worked on the Conor thread of
Detroit become human Nema fakar he
worked recently on the AC Mirage that
just came out and so they had one
composer who was doing all the kind of
narrative you know traditional music but
then they have this whole thing of
wanting to produce a world of diagetic
Music where there's like Street buskers
and and uh like performers playing
Arabic music throughout the streets and
they wanted somebody who lives and
breeds that to produce all that so
there's sort of like two totally
unrelated soundtrack albums from each
other of the inor music and the score
and they had two composers working you
know in tandem on syndicate it was the
same thing except it wasn't original
music but there was a whole separate
production doing all the street
performers singing like English hymns
and whatever on the street and like folk
songs and all the piano bar stuff and I
worked with them a tiny bit but
generally yeah so that's a reason why
sometimes but I don't know if you're if
I feel like if you build it as a
partnership
it can work great because you learn each
other's rhythms and things but I always
find it I've had a
few where it took a little bit it's like
dating but you're like except we're
trapped on a Lifeboat together so we're
like we better sort it out because we're
both signed a contract and like unless
one of us wants to be the one that [__]
us up uh and and you just don't know how
it how it can can go but I find it I
find it challenging I am always in awe
that that the two of them have made it
you know work so well and for so long
and because I find that I go down a
rabbit hole of like
psycho you know banging on the wall and
trying weird crap and then like to then
have to go oh right hey cohort you cool
with all this like my brain it's like
slamming on the brakes for me so that
can be challenging I don't know I
haven't figured I just probably
antisocial but I don't know no but
that's true how you felt with the cat
what's that your co-star the cat yeah do
you feel similarly to how Austin just
described you know you're just trying to
bang on the walls yeah I mean I had I
had a very particular way I wanted to do
the scene and the cat had their opinions
yeah the cat opon yeah well the cat won
cat did win yeah um cat also got covid
the cat did get Co I love this story
sorry Andy we'll come back to what you
were going to say then can you tell the
story about the cat getting Co I think
so I feel like you can Mike's spoken
about
So Co stuff the first day of the Leo
Loft stuff yeah by the way spoilers
everybody if you haven't seen The Fall
of the House
Sasha I have watched it I heard yeah how
many I saw all eight of them cool I'm
super
proud and that's that's it that's the
most of the review Austin has given
either A's review is I'm proud I watched
proud to have seen it awesome y this
year your fa for for
context I wouldn't have thought to drive
such
a hard line on this if Rahul hadn't
noticed that that I actually hadn't
offered an opinion he was like he's not
told us if it's good just that he's been
watching it I was like I was like and
tell death so it shall be challenge
accepted but anyway cat got Co this is a
thing well so what happened was
obviously we shot this last year when
there was still the covid restrictions
headlines and um it it I I I don't know
if I'm not sure Mike has done much press
I think he has yet like because of the
strikes but I mean I'm sure he'll say
that this was a very difficult shoot for
a multitude of reasons um and you know
we had where on midnight mass we didn't
have a single case of covid on user we
felt like we kept going down every few
weeks I got Co like the day before you
flew yeah so like you didn't get it
thankfully um but it was like oh my God
we have to separate you have to leave
yeah it felt like it it just that that
period of time it just was po it was
just happening almost every week or two
we'd hear someone got it so it was
always delayed um anyway so by the time
we got to this self-contained almost
episode which was uh Leo's Loft I I was
supposed to be shot out of the show
because of other schedules so the
character got kind of reduced to like
only really being in one
location and um it was going to take
about a week and a bit to do all of
Leo's Loft scenes which would cover
basically his his his Arc is that a real
loft or is it a set set it's super cool
yeah yeah yeah they did an incredible
job this is in
Vancouver yeah um but um but yeah so we
finally do our first scene we get to the
point now where we're going to do this
and we're expecting a pretty easy week
it's mainly just me rather than large
groups of actors um and um the first
scene was shot and then at
lunchtime uh Trevor Macy took me and
Flanigan out back to tell us that
someone had caught covid and that I was
close to them so they were whisked away
and so we had barely got through lunch
before we had an issue so we kind of
soldiered on finished the day the next
morning I came in and I could see
Flanigan was wearing his P95 mask but he
had tears and
I was like now what um and's that
empathy you're known for now what now
what's the problem um but it was like oh
God what what like it just felt like
anything that could go wrong on this
show was going wrong and fling had tears
and then he kind of broke it to me and
said that this morning Co took away our
cat because the cat was considered close
contact UM and was they were laugh to
tears yeah they were laughing laughing
to tears at just how ridiculous it was
so we only had two cats wait a minute is
that a thing can cats transmit Co this
feels like [__] think dogs and cats
can catch it felt like a [__] thing
that they were doing it didn't feel like
a level of Def like a level of uh
anxiety that sort of goes into Crazy
Town I wasn't taken away because I I I
they couldn't what are they gonna do
stay the person who had covid was around
both Rahul and the cat but they took the
cat away and not Rahul yeah and that's
when the crew all like oh maybe these
some of these guidelines are [__]
it's so
funny why is raho allowed on set with us
when we know we know he was like right
next to that person anyway that explains
why the whole cast by the end of the
shoot were a bunch of Hardcore redpilled
antivaxers that we're like yeah it's all
the [__] government
man exactly but um yeah so we had two
cats and there was they were they were
identical pretty much and they were
trained by the same trainer there was
one that could walk to Marks uh that you
set and then there was the other one
that was very good with people so it
would be still and and you could you
know hold it we lost the one that was
good with
people so the cat that couldn't be
touched that hated people but could walk
to Marks uh did the heavy lifting for
both cats so there's a scene where Leo
walks in holding the cat the replacement
and gets scratched that cat we did that
there was about 10 takes plus of just I
couldn't get past to my mark before the
cat would bolt that's so fle its way out
there's a few shots where the cat I
think must be CG right the marks are way
too specific and it I was I was kind of
it was really well done but I was
scrutinizing it going I think I'm I'm
fairly sure uh but it's getting harder
and harder to tell as as the years G
sure I don't think I remember though CU
When we saw the first cut there was
still tons of CGS
It's a combination of all of it really
there's a practical puppet that we used
in different stuff um that could Mo the
only one that struck me was where I just
thought that would be so [__] hard to
get with a real even the most well
trained cat in the world was the walking
over the dead body on the sidewalk so we
did do that for real really yeah we did
and is that you Rahul on the sidewalk or
you it was yeah and uh you had to heat
the ground that the only day CU it
snowed yeah it was the only day in
Vancouver that it snowed and it was me
on the sidewalk in downtown at 3:00 a.m.
and they were blowtorching the snow off
the sidewalk uh and I had to be
shirtless and didn't mark am come for
that one yeah Mark they they rang me in
advance when Mark would like to hang out
and set is that all right and I was like
yeah so he he walked in with his cute
little bubble hat uh at like 11: at
night cuz it was freezing in Vancouver
and he just stayed with me in the Green
Room for like 2 three hours just
chatting and what a yeah he's amazing
but anyway yes I assumed you used that
opportunity to heavily defend the
prequel
trilogy I did yeah yeah uh but I didn't
need to I think Mark's a big fan of the
prequels but we didn't talk we didn't
talk about the newer stuff I stayed off
that
topic well from from the uh from the
candid moments he had on uh red
carpets I suspect he wouldn't hold back
on opinions that I'm likely to agree
with but uh uh I have a question about
that
um the bit with smashing all the walls
with the Thor hammer yeah that stuff
does that
entail uh well how do how do I ask this
basically if if if did you have to shoot
that a bunch and they had to reconstruct
[__] or is that just like nope we're you
better [__] get it because it's like
it's a set but it's also not the biggest
deal I would think to throw up fresh
drywall and re like sets get re rebuilt
for things like that but still it you it
was very destroyed and I I kept
thinking like when you were talking
about it just wondering how how how much
for only a week you said for the whole
thing yes so so the the Smashing all of
all of that stuff was safe to the end
obviously because I was going to trash
that set um so that was so we got
everything we needed when it when it was
in a you know when it was as was and it
was goodlooking and then when we got to
those days I think it was two days worth
of of Carla and
I uh cat fighting started to throw
around some of the props and smash and
the
drywalls they
were uh staged in a way that they had
multiple walls to just
reinsert but it wasn't unlimited like
there was still pressure you didn't want
to like screw it up so you you know I
didn't have endless amount to go through
um maybe maybe three takes two three
takes and hope that we got it and they
were very specific about the problem was
I had to stay in a very kind of Rage
filled uncontrollable kind of thrashing
around but Michael fenari who was the
director of that episode
obviously was very specific about we had
certain places we had to hit for Focus
reasons but also for continuity and
things like that so there was this like
real hybrid of being absolutely kind of
Rage filled but super accurate about
where this Hammer's landing and you put
it right in this hole that first one as
well where I think Leo takes the frame
Off the Wall I remember that one being
because we did it as a Warner um I had
to be so specific and and I think they
put a tiny pencil Mark where I had to
hit it right in the middle they also
were going to I remember prop uh set
designers and stuff were talking about
pre-c scoring the drywall which would
make it easier to to does that mean so
they would go behind it and they would
score along the drywall to make it uh to
make it easier to break away you mean
like cut yeah I don't know what score
means I like that's what Andy does yeah
no they pre-core it with a knife
interesting so that when I hit it it
would as much but we for some reason we
didn't do that so each each single one
was just straight drywall and and two
days of it um so do they replace it then
they were they were having to replace
they you were just bring in sheets of
wall yeah we would just do a scene and
then we would take a break and then come
back and they'd have cleaned up all the
all the mess and um there were certain
things we couldn't keep doing like I
think I throw Leo's cabinet on to the I
think we left that till last and that
was a wner because I think I smashed
some of the picture frames in there and
some of the props but yeah that was what
about the the the end over the rail is
that is there something over the side
like well how how's that how's that all
going down there's a funny story with
that so I've had an issue in uh this is
a Canada issue um by one I've had one
stunt double his Named Sam I met him on
a zombie and he's a Fantastic Sam uh
Worthington from Avatar fame um but but
um I like Sam Neil better but continue
so Sam Sam whose name I'm last name I'm
blanking on right now but Sam was my
stunt double in in I zombie and they
managed to find a dude that was a
fantastic double for me you couldn't
tell and then Sam I think worked on the
Revenant and blew his knee out and we
lost Sam for a while and then I started
to deal with and not just on I zombie
but just in general with
Canada uh stunt performers in Brown
face uh and I was like this is a problem
why we we can't what how are we not able
to to find a proper stunt double for me
CU there just hasn't been really much of
a need and I don't think many South
Asians go into stunts um plus you're
inordinately tall and I'm a big yeah I
am a pain in the ass to double for we've
also had actors who are we've had uh
black stunt performers in in Brown face
like being it's just always been
problematic I'll always come into the
makeup room and see some stunt performer
getting some form of of skin transition
and I'm like Jesus anyway so
um our stunt coordinator on user found
um a South Asian stunt guy stunt
coordinator Christa she found a South
Asian guy to train up and was like right
we're gonna we're gonna get you in it's
your first gig and you're gonna be royal
Coy stump double and he had been waiting
for two days because I did a lot of the
stuff I don't that a lot of the
Breakaway stuff a lot of the fighting it
they weren't sure what I was wanting to
do what I didn't want to do so he was
always on standby and then I tried to
talk myself into jumping off the balcony
which was like a 15 foot drop onto pads
cuz it was an elevated stage um and Mike
and Christ and everyone was like don't
be an idiot and this guy had been
waiting for two days and I'd also
complain that there hasn't been a South
Asian
stunt they get me one and I'm like I got
it the next Tom
Cruz so uh he did it and he did a
fantastic job I think it's funny cuz I'm
quite doughy as Leo but if you watch it
in slow motion I as I run up off the
balcony and take a swing I fall off with
a
six-pack uh and I remember on set when
whenever the guy fell uh Flanigan would
play the willhelm screen and we were
like oh my God we should keep that in
that's amazing yeah so I need to check
my audio the levels just jumped in a way
that is slightly concerning see that
just went up by itself I don't like that
I uh another question I have this it's
not really an interview show but it sort
of become that uh but
I want to know what you had to do before
shooting to be worthy of lifting
Moler I play that's out of your hands I
feel like it was I think I got residual
worthiness from playing Sheriff Assan in
Midnight
Mass I was going to make a separate joke
about how I really liked how your
costume was inspired by Joel from The
Last of Us on House of
Usher Nice that whole that whole Viagra
scene you know in Jackson and Last of Us
Part Two classic classic really yeah
really yeah good good stuff people keep
asking about the game too what games you
were playing dumb question are you
actually playing the video game during
the
shots no none of them
right pre-recorded yeah because I was is
it on screen it's not it's not like a
green it wasn't keyed in no it was being
played through playback on the screen so
I could match and it was only short
because it's all it's all been cleared
through legal they they choose like
Mortal Kombat submitted their portion
cyber Punk submitted their portion and
then it was just played on the screen
for real um and then although it's
usually ke in wait Flanigan brought his
own PlayStation in did I play last you
were kind of like interacting with it
within the scene too as if like I don't
know I don't know if that it was just it
it played so like fluidly it seemed like
yeah yeah I think I got to match the PC
I did as well I think I got to match
what was on there so I watched it a few
times memorized what the player was
doing and then because I get annoyed
with video game playing if it's weird
but um but I do think I could be wrong I
remember Flanigan had his actual
PlayStation plugged in Leo's playing
Flanigan's one from his trailer and I
think I might have played last of us
last of us might have been one of the
only ones I can't I can't remember but I
I remember us having to muck around with
the controller um and charging it um I
was gonna ask Andy a question um on the
soundtrack why was my song The for when
the Black Cat why was that the only one
excluded from that album wow Andy
disrespect wow so there's certain cute
we're given like the album is like asked
to be a certain length to fit like a
maximum number of tracks and sometimes
if it's going to be vinyl it's like kind
of limited although they've been
expanding the vinyl range I think like
it used to be I feel like it used to be
22 minutes and now I feel like it's like
29 minutes is that do you know Austin is
it like 29 on a single side on a single
side Maybe I'm Wrong pretty long yeah I
feel like that that's probably wrong but
I feel like it's been expanded anyway
long story short Rahul that track got
cut because it was like basically it
came down to like violent tracks got cut
and that was like a super violent track
obviously it shouldn't have been cut
though and now I feel really bad now
violent as in like the music sounds
violent or in that it was playing in the
background of a violent scene that the
music is violent yeah interesting yeah
it's less of a musical experience
although in some cases it's it it it
plays really well because we got to hear
it on the stage and by itself that music
sounds so fun and like because it's
changing so much and doing there's so
much going on with it own of it who's
weighing in on that who's I've like I'm
not used to people inter like I've I
definitely like Netflix in particular
has a bit of a thing about the maximum
length of their albums we ran into this
on the Tai cave show where it was like 4
and a half hours of music and they were
like we'd like a 45 to 60 Minute album
and I was like it's going to be 90 and
just embrace it and even then we are
cutting the sh really long for an album
for a soundtrack of a whole season of
Television that's that's like that's
like you're hour it's nothing yeah it's
exact I mean and it's it's not like the
old days where CDs were the governing
thing where the maximum you could get on
a CD was like 72 minutes on the dot that
was like the absolute high-end and so
that's how long but even then most
people were like yeah they don't need to
be that most cues are not like don't
need to be there but still over this
much runtime you know or you could do
the Mandalorian thing where they just go
how about one soundtrack for every
episode or like rings of power where
they did the same uh but so anyway you
were told maximum runtime but also they
were giving you like creative editorial
no not no no no they didn't so basically
it started actually on midnight mass on
midnight mass we had so much music
because there were the hymns there were
these like long sort of pieces that
Indulgence on the part of the organ
player that guy don't get me started on
that guy and he plays the in Midnight
Mass he literally portrays the organ he
is he is playing he is he is the organ
being played by an actor the or yeah
yeah the organ um they uh so on midnight
mass we had we put we were like [__] it
let's put it oh I shouldn't I don't know
if I can no no no you fine go ahead okay
okay [__] it the fact that you're not in
a suit and tie also this is a pretty
pretty buttoned up Podcast sorry yeah
but I do appreciate that you were
standing for the whole of it yeah very
nice um on midnight mass we really
wanted to put everything out because
everything was so deliberate that we did
for midnight mass um and we really
wanted to reflect the whole show when we
did that though we weren't thinking
about vinyl we were just thinking about
we want the hymns we want all the like
the the peace on the beach and all the
crazy pieces and the nice pieces we
wanted everything to come together well
then when it came time for the vinyl
they were like cool we can only this is
how many this is what we're limited to
unless we do like eight vinyl it wasn't
gonna be eight I think it was going to
be it was GNA have to be four four
vinyls and it was just ridiculous as far
as like production costs and everything
so the idea was we had to like Wrangle
it down so this time uh we were trying
to learn from our our mishaps and we
were trying to like put the soundtrack
together in a way where
we could do we could mirror the rele the
digital release with the vinyl
release but it still sucks and now I
feel really bad that that no I'm joking
I'm I I I um no it should be also I'm I
I've been listening to is it at last oh
yeah at last yeah at last it's like I
listen to that almost every day or when
I'm when I'm out about on town I I I
mean I I've I've loved every everything
I've been with you now since what BL
Mana yeah um and you guys have always
done right by me like every monologue
you you've helped me dignity dignity was
a good one but like every monologue you
guys have taken from like a six to a 10
for me just by helping you know I'm
trying to force out a single tier and
then but you guys are right there like
underscoring Andy when it comes to
something like a monologue are you do
you start the process of composing when
you're reading the script or do you wait
to see the scenes or like at what time
are you composing seen like that that's
a good question M thanks yeah I mean
it's a little of each with especially
with Flanigan it's a little of each like
usually it's like he'll send the script
early on we'll write things to the
script um but then as things get
shot everything changes and sometimes
things from the script work sentiments
from the script work themes from the
script work but oftentimes then when the
the footage comes in everything starts
to sort of change and and everyone
starts to you know kind of adjust and I
mean huge props and this is where like
Flanigan and Macy like when they're when
they're sort of when we're doing like
playbacks for you know like midnight
mass is a is a great example when we're
doing playbacks they have a very good
sense of like what first what what they
want to achieve in the spotting we want
to achieve this let's go for this and
then we'll execute a version of that and
then they'll have very specific ideas of
how we can craft it by just doing little
things um there's actually in episode
seven there's a scene where Mike had an
idea to score Carla's dialogue exactly
to her words but just for one moment at
the end of her dialogue and I'll send
you the I'll send you the the cue but it
comes together like really nicely and
and you know it was a brilliant idea
from Mike he was like Hey you know in
the score right at this section when
Carl is doing this thing could you have
the violins actually play the melody you
have in here but have the melody play
around her like with exact words of her
just for like five or six syllables it
was like really subtle but his ability
and and Trevor's ability to sort of see
these things and like bring them
together I mean I give big big props to
the two of them for you know being able
to sort of articulate um because it's a
tricky thing you know like talking M
like Austin you know like some people
talk music better than others it's I
almost find it easier when people talk
no musical lingo and they talk feelings
like I want to feel sadder more heroic
or like this way as opposed to like
maybe we should go minor here and then
and that's okay too but I prefer it
almost never means what they think it
means or they they don't realize it's
it's it it I always say to them you know
imagine if I just look at a script or
the better way to phrase it is when an
executive looks at your script and just
takes one random line in isolation goes
can't it just be this and like the
writer is feeling the domino effect in
all directions that that causes that is
very similar to when they'll just go
can't you just be minor here it's like
well sometimes if we're lucky a change
like that might be exactly the right
thing but then I'm also trying to like
put together a a larger hole so let's
think about what's the goal that we're
chasing here is it is it that the scene
is not heavy enough is it that the scene
is is coming across you know laterally
like it's it's it's supposed to be
Darkly funny but there's no sense of
irony to it is it that it's just simply
too fast is it that it's moving too much
is there is there just the music is
overstating its case or we're in the way
of the actors or or blah blah blah blah
blah you just like start unpacking
what's the fundamental goal of the scene
H and because yeah in my experience
almost never does it help to to uh in
direct musical terms uh and Mike Mike is
a like Mike he's a musician right Mike
Mike's a good so good he's like the
visual would be like uh uh you know when
Skywalker shows up at the end on top of
the mountain from uh oh which awakens
horse awakens at the very end you know
that scene I think of Mike like there'll
be there'll be moments where we're like
trying to crack a queue and it's like
80% there but we're trying to land one
thing and Mike will be in the studio and
he'll just say like wait what key are we
in like oh in whatever C minor he'll
walk over and just like what if we go
you're here you're doing this what if we
go to this boom and he'll just like he's
done it multiple times like what if we
go to that and it and it works very
that's very atypical I was talking to
Brett who's uh the editor on Usha for
maybe like an hour on the weekend just
being like how does this work and he had
so much positive stuff to say about Mike
and uh FY who uh what's his full name
Michael fi Michael fanari who directed
with Mike
in a way just like yeah um like because
he's got a back a background in editing
he almost shoots like an editor in some
ways so he can give all this advice to
an editor that a lot of people can't I
feel like Mike must be a very he can
also Act is the other Anno and do
accents yeah um and can play music and
can edit and it's it's yeah I mean it's
a he even looks he even looks amazing as
a stunt double in Brown face
uh he also he also which most people a
lot of people don't know he sings in
Midnight Mass right he's on the he sure
does he single takes he came over to the
studio one morning single like didn't
even really need the sheet music of the
hymns just stepped right up to the mic
and we were like yeah just go right up
there we hit spacebar and just single
takes of like eight verses of you know
Catholic hymns as we did them and he
just sing right through it and he
finished the first take of one he took
the you know the headphone off he's like
we good and we're like we are let's do
the next one like just like that crazy I
mean I feel like everyone involved in
this show is so talented like it's such
a good cost across the board like
everyone's just so fun to watch it's so
bombastic I I uh I just realiz it was
driving me nuts I was like why the hell
do I know this name of Michael
fingar um he dpd on one of my favorite
films I've ever scored I just realized
really a long a long time ago yeah next
time you talk to him ask him about a
movie called leave um yeah director this
saint of a human being director from New
York named Bob
celestino um and uh the film is like
truly just this amazing the two of the
actors from Band of Brothers all those
guys are all still super close like
they're lit just a Band of Brothers
still and um they all were young that
was kind of their launching pad for most
of them in their career to all be
working actors and and so but as they
you know started pushing 40 they all a
lot of them started turning to more
writing producing uh that kind of stuff
and and so two of the guys Frank John
Hughes and Rick Gomez uh wrote produced
and star in this film that Bob uh
directed and Michael shot um and um
[__] great I was one of those I was
like God I've heard this name a thousand
times um and it was driving me crazy
trying to remember why sorry to in but I
was like sitting here going yeah it was
you know typical fate of a lot of Indie
sort of thrill it's great little film
it's got Brian cranon in it also and and
the two of them you know they both named
their characters after their real life
sons and like really got into like they
spent months workshopping the the script
together and and Frank and Rick and um
so good so actually I use the story of
that film all the time sorry to derail
all this discussion but there was a um
it's who you are Austin it's fine I know
it's true um the um uh I I a lot younger
I'm sure you have this also Andy that
younger composers will often you know
just or like you speak to a Berkeley
class or you CLA class or something and
there's often like the last thing before
you leave is you know do you have any
general advice and the thing I often
have landed on is um it's better to be
sort of to embrace choices that may be
divisive knowing you might not get the
job um than to kind of be this milk
toast I'll do whatever you want uh you
know very kind of
unopinionated person with no perspective
and I always use that film uh called
leave as my example where I I so the How
I Got That was another one of the banded
Brothers guys is is an actor named Ross
McCall and I had scored a movie that he
was in and we ended up hanging out after
the film was over and got along really
well and and and he pitched me to these
buddies were having a hard time finding
a composer that was working out on their
film leave so he goes I I know this guy
you should you should meet him and he I
had given like I had had a few albums
come out on CD at that point and he gave
them to them and I get this breathless
phone call from Ross he's got this thick
Scottish accent and he's like hey bud I
gave your CDs I hope that's okay these
guys are my favorite people ever in this
industry they're the best this again
with the Scottish accent I wouldn't
dream of it um Ross is a really really
good dude though and um and yeah he
pitched me hard to these guys and so I
just get a call cold call from these two
actor friends and they're like we're
gonna we're you know uh come we'd love
to meet you we're at we're at little
Doms in Los felis uh and so I go drive
down there and they're like we'd love
for you to you know pitch on this film
and I I had it in my mind I was like I'm
going to see if I can talk them out of
making me demo and if I can just get the
job just by sheer force of will which
you know I had I had a chip on my
shoulder about writing demos back in
those days um and so uh so they were
like look we're both actors and we will
spend two weeks you you get a few pages
you have to imagine the Arc of this
character because you don't even
necessarily have the full script you
spend two weeks crafting it nailing it
you go in you audition they tell you
that was [__] awesome you're just
like 4 inches too short for the the roll
or you're 4 inches too tall or this or
that or we're casting this person
opposite you and we we think that the
chemistry is going to work or like a
thousand reasons why you're perfect and
somehow not like you can be great but
not right yeah and as an expression I
heard at some point that I stuck with me
as well and so they're like you on the
other hand can just go get this job like
none of that shit's gonna interfere with
you you can just go ride a kickass demo
and so it was their way of saying like
Get over yourself and so I go okay I
have one request can I watch the because
they wanted me to take a crack at the
opening scene and I said can I watch the
whole movie first at least and they were
like okay fine so they go here's a DVD
it's only about 90 minutes we're gonna
just sit here and keep having coffee so
I raced home I watched it I came back
they're still at the same table that's
so funny and I was blown away I'm like
in tears I thought this movie was
unbelievable and so I was like without
any music I feel like music well it had
it had temp you know just like random
crap thrown in there and and it worked
fine you know it was very ambient and
but just it's one of these movies that
does not go where you think it's going
to go and I was so blown away and their
performances were amazing like you could
tell that this was built they they knew
every word backward and forward they had
produced it written it like you could
feel that this was such a labor of love
and thank God I watched the whole thing
because it gave me this idea of like I
can kind of bury the lead in the opening
scene I can hint at what this is going
to be in a way that if you then go back
and watch it you're like oh [__] they
were they were telegraphing in a super
subtle way what this was right out of
the gate and so I put together got in
brought in singers and crazy musicians
and we were doing weird [__] where we're
like taking you know cello bows on
styrofoam cups and you know all this
stuff and I sent it off and I'm like
[__] in the bag director calls me and
who I hadn't met he lives in New York
and he calls me and he goes everything
about what you did was wrong for this
scene this was absolutely not right but
it was so crazy that you should be the
guy to score this film so he's like
we're going to start blank page but I
want someone who's willing to take those
kinds of wild swings um and it was like
such a light bulb this was 14 years ago
something like that it was like a crazy
light bulb career moment of I'd so much
rather get a job this way i' also rather
not get a job if someone who takes wild
swings is a huge turn off for the
director and they're going
H you know this this I kind of want
someone who's going to more or less just
you know 145 their way through the scene
and that's that uh I was like I I just
click with people like this guy um and
so anyway that was dpd by m Michael
fingar there's my reason yeah there's my
and I'll tell you I'll just to give a
bit of context on how long I've known
Andy um I might have the timeline of
this wrong because I've mythologized
this a little bit in my head over the
last decade plus but two things happened
in quick succession with each other I
was sharing a studio with a composer
named John debney at the time he owns
this building by the Warner Brothers lot
and his outfit is upstairs and he had
some rooms and I was in one of them um
down on the lower floor and John has you
know done a million big films uh Oscar
nominee for The Passion of the Christ
done a lot of fa movies like elf and
zura and Iron Man 2 and Jungle Book and
uh Tom shadec movies Liar Liar Bruce
Almighty Etc ET ET ET a lot of comedies
in particular he also works on the
Orville uh now for Seth McFarland old
school orchestral but he's done a lot
he's done a ton of stuff like [__] tons
of stuff and um and
so uh one day this guy knocks on the
door uh uh like literally I think it was
just like you I think if memory serves
John goes hey you should go introduce
yourself to the guy downstairs right
because you two are old friends and so I
just like some random dude knocks on the
door and I had no idea who you were and
and I want to hear your ver like your
side of that in case I'm missing up but
the funny thing was so in parallel
around that same time this was like 12
13 years ago for I do not remember where
the connection came from but I randomly
got asked to pitch on a film and exactly
like the story I just told I pitched the
weirdest [__] approach be but unlike
that other I couldn't watch the whole
film they just sent me two scenes and I
had no idea what was what and so I wrote
some weird [__] I recorded myself
drumming with paper with colored pencils
on a tambourine and like all this weird
I it was like a bunch of weird it was
not I recorded the sound of tearing
paper and made a like percussion out of
it and all this stuff D did not get the
job this guy got the job and I had no
idea who who he was uh well the Newton
Brothers got the job and I was like who
the [__] is that and it was like it was
in my mind the next day you knock on the
door and then it was like oh you're that
you're the Newton brother brother uh
what a weird wow yeah that was the movie
Detachment wait and then did you like go
without speaking until
recently I fully thought I in the two of
you for some reason I did not realize
each other before
not at all not at all we had met that
day and I remember that day because I
remember coming into your room and you
had you had all the scores on CD you had
you had you had a whole wall full of
scores which is like for composers
that's like a wet [__] dream like
it's all you all you want to do is like
listen to scores talk about scores like
listen like talk to other people about
them where were they read the liner
notes and I walked into your room and
you had right didn't you have I recall
like a Shelf full of like CDs of scores
and also uh conductor scores big and
it's and and things have not changed
there's uh you can't really see the um
the CDs are behind the black thing here
but there and yeah there's also sheet
music just all over the floor um yeah we
we didn't know any we don't know each
other really but because of that we just
started talking about scores I and I
don't even remember the specifics but I
remember you started with like oh you
familiar with this score and that we
just started rapping and it was just a
real uh easy conversation very nerdy we
should have done Detachment
together again the triplets bring them
back the hilarious thing that up the
full circle on that one is that a couple
years ago I got asked to produce a score
for Adrien Brody because he wanted to
try to score a movie um and it was it
was a director that I do all of his
movies and so the director was like how
about you work with my guy and he was
always he was very like he carries this
um like how to describe it it it bums
him out that more people didn't see that
film because he's like he was like I I I
gave everything I had to that role and I
really feel like it that film actually
really kind of like it added up into
something you know because he goes
sometimes you show up on set and then
you watch the film at the premiere and
you're like boy that's different than
what I thought it was going to be and
you feel a little like like shrinking
down in your seat and he was you know
you could feel that there were some
movies he had done that he was less
excited about but that one he was like
it's a shame that no one saw that movie
uh and uh and yeah he he was real
excited he was you know wanted to and I
was like you know what's funny is I
pitched on that he was like what the
[__] what was your demo if if Austin was
out there using pencils on tambourines
and shredding paper what did you do so I
I remember getting those scenes too
Austin it's funny like I remember
getting the scenes and not having the
context which is really difficult
because you don't have a lot to like
you're you know like yeah the you don't
even really know what genre movie it is
like it's it's one of those you just
it's like a scene of a teacher in a
classroom you're similar to what Raul
has to deal with with audition
scripts yeah yeah I mean that must like
Rahul when you get an audition for a
script like you could go in a thousand
different directions right even if
you're given a g Direction like Andy
sorry to derell but I I can talk about
it now I didn't know but I auditioned
for
tenant
right Christopher Nolan so here's what
they told for the Kenneth BR RW though I
still don't know all I got for tenant
was Christopher
Nolan
audition oh and then dummy sides no
character name no oh like fake fake line
like like to avoid leaks and stuff a
fake monologue that was nothing to do
with the show I wasn't told age
race uh accent location nothing Chris
Nolan this date put yourself on tape and
I was like how do I maximize my
opportunity here what's he looking
for how do I do anything and it's so
you're just pissing in the dark right
and then uh obviously I didn't hear back
but like yeah it can be frustrating
sometimes like yeah you don't even know
what that character actually is in theie
movie like you literally have zero idea
but I I never know I'll never find out
because I I um I'm quite mature and I
don't hold grudges any show that I
audition for that I don't get cast in I
never watch so I never I haven't seen
tenant the only noan film i't watched I
ain't seen ring of power um I have to be
careful I could mess up ndas here but
yeah I don't watch him if also I just
want to say audio listeners if my if my
microphone is jumping around apologies I
guess video listeners as well I can see
that our levels keep going up now it
might be annoying I I don't know this I
want to throw something to you how did
you and Mike and Taylor start working
together what was the was it was it Hill
House no it was before then right yeah
it was oculus Oculus say I know this
story too because Molly Elfman and I got
coffee around that time and she was
talking all about this guy Mike Flanigan
oh who who directed me Mary Elfman in
next exit yeah which is great by the
that was oh oh it right yeah yeah yes
yeah uh we met Mike on Oculus and we
came in just as like an interview and it
was like strangely and and and greatly
that's the wrong adverb for that but
like it was in person which is so rare
these days usually it's just do a demo
send in a demo or whatever this was like
they interviewed some people uh in
person um who hooked that up like how
did what who made that connection I
think that that came through I want to
say that that came through Cutting
Edge really had they were they repping
you or something like they were
connected to um Becca Nelson who was our
agent at the time and a music agenc
cutting edges connected to aridell that
was the I think they owned aridell they
owned yeah yeah and so we were with
aridell at the time an agency and so we
it's just yeah it was just like
so this is one of those weird I didn't
know you ever they're mostly British
composers but because air air is this
British company they also like the most
one of the most famous recording studios
in the world air air Studios um I'm
pretty sure was part of that same kind
of conglomerate um but they were owned
by Cutting Edge which was is
still um this weird I don't even know
how to describe it because there's
they're like a unique um they're
essentially like a music library meets
production company that will comp like
Studios will make a deal with them and
say hey if you pitch in some of the
money for the cost of our composer and
our score you'll re you get to have the
rights to it to then sub license out for
other thing so they're like running kind
of like a side hustle uh to to you know
maximize the tail in profits on the
music in exchange for taking the burden
of production and all that off of a
given produ that's their pitch at least
my agents I feel like a lot of Agents
really don't like them um H and they can
be very challenging to deal with uh I've
had limited experience with them and
they were
medium I would
say what was the oh yeah it was about
Andy and Taylor Mee yeah it was just a
yeah and honestly it's you know how
those meetings go you walk in the room
you talk about music you and it's like
you're not sure if you'll get it or not
uh and we got it and it was you know we
we jumped right into it with with Mike
and Trevor I mean everyone was sort of
like no
demo does interview is it just like if
you're interviewing for a composing
position is it like just making sure you
understand a Vibe like what kind of
questions do you get in an interview
like that usually all kind like I mean I
find that the best interviews I feel
like are the ones in person where you
can decide if you sort of get along
because like every project is like a bit
of a marriage it's it's you need to it's
the first date and you you'd like to
have another date assuming you both you
know get along and you know have similar
interests and whatever making sure you
you would enjoy walking together I guess
in step one yeah yeah and it's weird
because early on in our career I feel
like I just wanted to have a second date
like let's go on the first I just wanted
all like we want you want you want to
work with people you want to yeah and
now it's now it's become a little I've
tried to be a little more patient with
like oh I really like this film but like
we just don't get along like this you
know there's certain not not not get
along but there's just not you know it's
it's difficult because you're you know
in any creative Endeavor I mean I'm sure
like rul you've probably been on set
where on a variety of projects where
maybe you disagree with how you're being
asked to do a certain thing sure and and
sometimes there's compromise but I bet
sometimes they're like no no no we just
want you to like like you do it as we
told you to do it yeah we want you to
just do it and and that's and that's the
tricky line and I think that that's I
feel really lucky to have been you know
Taylor and I both to brought into like
be with the sort of flane because Mike
is so sort of suggestive with ideas and
then interested in like hey I gave you
this idea and you gave me this that's
yeah the collaboration between and that
like really gets me off like that's
where I really because
I feel like that's where you see things
really start to become interesting when
ideas start to expand past a place where
you can see them does that make sense
like yeah yeah you would never think
like midnight mass I never would have
thought that we're gonna have like you
know 45 seconds of Silence in the middle
of a piece of scor q but like Flanigan
wanted something really like it needed
to really tell you something about how
to feel in the scene and so that was you
know one of a few ideas of of ways to
execute it what scene what scene was
that that was on the it started on the
beach actually the whole be beginning of
episode two with the amazing camera work
super long Warner big one [__] one
your first days was that was my first
day yeah is that a crane Rahul how did
that whole thing how did that one
question how did they do that was
handheld isn't it it was handheld that's
right oh God I don't remember anything
but doesn't it end and it like pulls out
no I think it's handheld they just do a
UI I think it was handheld I think it's
James I think it's it might be Jimmy uh
I can't remember um yeah but but then so
you've been with on everything Flanigan
related since Oculus since Oculus yeah
oh wild yeah okay that's damn that's
awesome very obvious that that's a guy
that people love working with
considering every single actor also
appears in every single produ like
that's such a testament I feel that
alone just just looking at the recurring
yeah roster cuz at some point if
someone's an
[__] people are just going to turn it
down you know like yeah like very few
especially at that level it's not like
it's not like everybody is so starved
for opportunity that they're they'll
overcome their hatred just to to do it
like you know it it's it's really
obvious that that that is just a both
ways I think is that like everyone who's
being asked to return has got to be
people that Mike considers to be very
easy to work with and enjoys working
with as well for sure probably everyone
together like if you hated one of the
other actors you probably wouldn't want
to do it you know it's like it's a
testament to all of those people like
100% good people included there for sure
I think that's that's exactly when you
were asking what gets asked in those
meetings it's that kind of thing it's
the it's not like they don't ask job
interview questions you just shoot the
[__] and talk about life and and make
sure that you're on the same wavelength
because you want to know that when the
pressure is on and like things are due
yesterday and you're behind budget under
budget all that stuff like that that um
that it's somebody that you genuinely
like being in that situation with
because then you'll then you'll do
whatever it takes you know uh it's it's
that's it's yeah someone telling you do
it again I it's not working let's start
from scratch that needs to be someone
that you're like they're not I know
they're not saying that because they're
an [__] they're saying it because we
haven't found it yet and I will do
anything for someone I care about even
if it means totally burning to the
ground something I just spent a week
working on you know I I want to say
something for both of you actually
because I think it's such a wonderful
relationship that um I I I when I was at
drama school it never really clicked for
me um I struggled with learning in that
environment Stanis lasy and technique
and things like that and nothing clicked
for me until I kind of went off the
rails a bit I remember I was watching
Gangs of New York making
off and I I was probably one of the
middling students in the group sort of
there not going to really do anything
and then I I heard behind the scenes
which is so funny now full circle Henry
Thomas is in gangs in New York but
anyway so I'm watching the the DVD and
they say that Bill the Butcher Daniel
Lewis was playing Eminem in his
trailer and I was like oh now why is
that happening right why is he listening
to old school Eminem for Bill the
Butcher and I was like because that
music resonates with him and it allows
him to keep in character and he's ass
signing a playlist right so I thought
well what I'm being taught isn't working
let me I'm such a big fan of score and
music let me try that and all of a
sudden my work and my character work
just just like went I just leaped up the
class a little bit and I started to
learn so I create playlists I'm I'm when
I have my headphones in at work um
that's what I'm doing I I usually I I'll
read the script and start getting an
idea and I start putting a little mini
plays together depending on who the
character is and then I'll have songs
that are either for the character or for
the emotion so for instance I should
really do that for writing oh yeah yeah
absolutely I know a lot of Writers Do
like if I had like a mood playlist keeps
you there it's a really good and it's
such a quick shortcut you know so for a
good a good example of it's midnight
mass you know when the church has G gone
to [__] and we're doing that obviously I
did a lot of the the heavy lifting on
the fighting I was I the thing I was
fighting three four five stunt guys all
over the place the whole time I was
listening to Mick Gordon Doom maternal
uh the only the uh the only one they
fear is you and it's like down out right
so I'm listening to to that constantly
and then when it comes to seeing the
show you guys have scored on top of that
so it's like this lovely which then I'll
use like Usher so you know what I'm
saying like comp comp and we just keep
coming back full circle so I use other
scores okay great example midnight mass
whole shoot Eno Marone all of it the
whole playlist Sheriff Assan on my phone
is 90% Eno maracon Nick K Cinema
Paradiso uh we got that's a joke it's
the most I know it's I know it's 100%
not what you were listening to although
that would be interesting it was it was
all dollars Trilogy andu that for the
sheriff and then it was Nick Cave um the
the assassination of Jesse James
soundtrack um and then like yeah and
then so that that's the soundtrack of
the actor on the day and then obviously
you don't know what's going to come when
you guys see our footage and then you
know bring that to it I say that mention
of Austin CD you do the same thing you
love a a good score love a good score
Austin took me to the Opera that's true
you actually just before the call all
weekend F fig than listening to the
songs we heard at the Opera because
Austin took us I I saw I saw your thing
on Instagram and I sent it to Andrea and
I was like job well done I love it had
such a good time if I can when I feel
something like even that piece of music
it goes in the phone and I don't know
when oh look at that oh yes nice yeah do
a little do a
little but like I I'll use that I don't
know when but that piece of music gets
me a little bit excited and a little bit
jolly and Andy happy I've always my mom
said that was the first thing I reacted
to as a baby was music like I think most
kids do but like it would she could just
play music and I'd be happy and and I
would B so I've always had such a strong
relationship to it so like Barbara
Seville if I'm stuck if I'm finding it
difficult on set to do something I'm
going to crank that up because I know I
know it's I know how it makes me feel so
I I keep these little checklists here's
a you guys Inspire Inspire us twice for
me anyway so here's a question related
to that then uh if you let's say you
spent I'll just make up that you had a
month uh before you're like well you're
kind of in prep before you're really
shooting on midnight mass and let's say
you're just Round the Clock listening to
Dollars Trilogy stuff and other kind of
Leone Vibe
music and then at some
point Mike's like oh I like re
interesting I what I was kind of
picturing him much more of a you know
Tim Allen uh or whatever you know like
this is Home Improvement Vibe you know
like yeah well you're and is that one of
those where you
go this is a way I internalize it and
it's not it's not going to impact how we
shape the character or would you have to
like build a new playlist at that point
because it's just it's going to keep
pulling you a place that's at odds with
the direction that needs to go some
communication error has happened in some
major way for that to get that bad um
but you get what I'm asking like how
much of this how much of this are you
deliberately trying to manifest so
outwardly that actually the at some
point the playlist itself would have to
change because it's actually it's
actually interfer going interfering yeah
I mean that's happened I think not so
much with character building that will
happen for my day stuff so like if I
think this scene is
inherently sad and I've somehow misread
what the intentions were which can you
know you can sometimes get completely
wrong and they're like no no no it's not
that intense we didn't think it was that
big a deal I'll jets in the song that I
had lined up for that day that I would
have been using I'm like oh that's not
needed why do I need to listen to that
but like where like the midnight Mass
Sergio Le only thing came from was it
was simply
because I I KN I knew in confidence that
Flanigan didn't know I was gonna jizz
Clint Eastwood everywhere that was that
was never disussed what was disgusted
was was when he when he pitched it to me
and told me what the story was I was
like hold on there's this amazing these
two amazing things at war with each
other here right because you've got
isn't the sheriff especially in cinema
one of the most iconic American heroes
of all time
right the small town sheriff and then
isn't the bearded Brown Muslim one of
the alltime greatest villains of classic
hero archetype right and I was like oh
you've smooched them together because
he's got he's that but he's the sheriff
and and I so so I had said which I which
so it was int it's not fluke obviously
he was doing that on purpose but I was
like okay well I know this bit does does
the the the the Muslim Brown guy bearded
guy how do I get that sheriff bit to
translate and it was through
channeling certain
poses and just ways that like the old
guys would post up on the hip that's
where the music came from the hips we
Terry Anderson our costume designer
who's been our costume designer most of
the stuff he's awesome um I remember
speaking to him about Silhouettes
because I was like I don't want the
audience to be hit over the head with it
but like it'd be real nice if it feels
familiar without them knowing it's
familiar and and and I was like how do
we make a wild west outfit look modern
without anyone like really realizing
we're doing on Wild Wild West so I was
wearing cowboy boots under my jeans so
you could see I had that silhouette on
the leg but the front of the boot just
looked like any old standard work boot
and then we we we settled on the double
denim kind of look and and the copper
badge on the
outside um so like I wouldn't have and
Mike knew it was going that way I
don't yeah I don't think I would
misunderstand him that although actually
funny enough Mike and
I I can count like the amount of minutes
him and I have had character discussion
and I don't know if that's that's part
of why Mike likes working with me is I I
kind of get it pretty fast I yeah and he
leaves me a lot he sort of leaves me to
my devices and I come back and and I
don't [__] the bed maybe that's why but
like my first conversation with him for
in blind Manor um I'd already auditioned
and booked it so but so I wasn't being
met it was just like a hey welcome to
Vancouver Welcome to our show I think
the first thing I said to him was what's
you and McGregor like because he had
just done doct to sleep and then we
spent most of chat doing that and then
he said you how do you feel about the
character I said I'll do whatever you
want and then I that might be our only
character meeting nice Leo Usher I I
remember messaging him I I think you
have IDE is really fast but they're
super yeah like I'll get an instant
thing and he'll he'll know immediately
to be like uhuh that's wrong I remember
him saying on Usher I sent him pictures
of this model who was tatted up neck
tattoos hand tattoos wearing suits and
he had like Edge you know faded hair on
the side and I was like I'm getting this
Vibe and I remember Mike was like cool
but remember you're not a prick charm he
kept saying something to me in text
charm don't lose the charm I need you to
still be Charmed for some reason wasn't
he wanted this sibling to not be an out
and out yeah he didn't want me to be an
out andout
[__] that was but other than that I
It wasn't until we shot our first scene
and then I just remember him across the
room going Andy prep then go on to
inform you like how much do the
Aesthetics of the show inform your work
in it like are you looking it you know
stills of the way that rul looks in a
scene and does that actually inform the
music that you end up writing
it more about feeling it does so
Aesthetics play Big partt too yeah
aesthetic yeah it all play I think it
all plays into like the the vibe of of
what's Happening you know and and how
that's sort of like brought across
musically because it could go so many
different directions um and in this case
it was kind of like middle of the road
like instrumentation wise because the
idea was that it would it would be this
sort of train in the middle of what's
happening and have all the you have all
these crazy
happening um and the idea was that the
music would sort of just take you
through it without being too of a like
you know without giving you too much
feeling I think was the for most of it
um is it fair to say that the score was
also meant to be a bit of a tera Firma
since every episode is almost like a
short film uh obviously taking these
individual short stories of Edgar and
Poe and like it obviously has a larger
through line as a series but each one is
almost Standalone it would be very
tempting to musically make them so
stylized and unique that it's like eight
scores it felt like the music was
actively trying to be the opposite of
that it felt like the score was like we
want you to be one of the few things
that feels recurring so that you're not
lost yes that's exact that's exactly
right sound sounds like you liked it or
didn't that sounds like uh just disate
analysis this was just I'm just calling
it for what it
is yeah but that's exactly right it was
like let's hit the let's hit the four
basic thematic ideas and have those
maintained throughout you know like uh
because there's so much going on I mean
just the way episode two ends it's just
like oh [__] this is what's this is
what's happening we're GNA really [__]
some people up here um so I think that
it was uh response to that one online
has been really fun like we've seen some
people do like reaction videos to the
show where they like watch it and and
like react live I guess I guess um oh
really and yeah the end of episode two
there're all these people being like Oh
my God like they didn't see it coming
it's so brutal especially I think from
from Mike even though he's like the
horror director like I think pretty next
people are people are always expecting
something now emotional emotional and
and to see him just be like watch this
it's because he's not a Gore Fest horror
that's not you know it's not like
slasher movie kind of stuff you know had
that in him right like I feel like he
can do a payoff it's it's not a it's not
what I love about his work in general is
that um it's an earned thing it's not
just like a stepping stone to the next
scene it's like a [__] well we're at the
end of the First Act someone's got to
die or what it's like things like that
church Mayhem at the end of midnight
mass is so earned by that point like the
show I I know I mentioned to the other
day but I've spent the last few years
telling people that that that show is
watching someone pull back a bow like a
bow like his master Marksman bow and
arrow uh shooter I get whatever the
Archer
uh uh like take aim for seven episodes
um and then finally Let it Loose because
it's just tension building in such an
extreme uh restrained kind of way that
to me is what makes it fly off the rail
so well you know it's so it's so
calculated it's not just like oh [__]
the audience is bored let's throw some
chaos at them it's never that just
completely off topic is this the first
playwatch listen you've done since
Austin got Grammy nominated which I was
gonna mention at the end o o
Austin and technically uh has been I've
been bragging about it Austin all week
to family I'm like any of you lot been
nominated for a Grammy or anything no
you are on a Grammy nominated I'm yeah
technically you're getting me a OT I my
favorite uh my favorite is I have a
composer friend named Allan who's like a
musical theater guy and he posted a
photo once with Alan manin and he goes
Allan manin eight-time Oscar winner for
all the Disney musicals of the late '
80s early 90s and he's like here's two
alens who write musicals between us
we've won eight
Oscars I always thought that was one of
the best photo captions uh but uh huge
props Austin it's yeah congrats yeah
it's it's huge it it's uh well it's very
kind it it uh it was yeah it was it was
fun it was you know was obviously
Strays um you get some game awards
nominations as well I assume so I
haven't looked at the list I'm happy to
say that GameSpot made an entire article
out of uh the 100% snubbing uh way it is
it is literally an article that uh I'm
so surprised to hear that that's nuts
wow it it is it is I I cannot say I was
surprised um game awards is very like
the the jury is so International and so
big that it it very much is a biggest
marketing budget type thing they also
don't know what they're doing last year
I had to present rag rock with the award
for best writing
right bit of a conflict
yeah like this is this is the coverage
this is I just threw it in the chat this
made me this made me laugh that St get
that's so oh we got snubbed because they
mentioned you get a Grammy award but not
game awards like I love that like
theoretically this is an article about
the five scores that were nominated the
Grammys but they they they make the
headline about stray Gods because prec
but actually the funny thing all five in
both have zero overlap all five Grammy
nominees are also not at the game awards
didn't get oh that would have been last
year last year you did last year oh for
anyone hasn't seen it I have a clip up
on Twitter I think I might have clipped
it on Twitch as well where Rahul and I
were playing through the game and react
to rahul's song the first time and it's
just so much fun the delivery of oh I'm
not saying saying your fat is just so
good it's incredible um but yeah the
gameward devastating I said it to Austin
and Troy but I was I I recorded that at
a time where I was very unhappy
professionally with a what some work I
was doing and it was causing it was I
was having those questions which I
haven't had to ask for a while you know
like do you like this do you want to
keep doing this are you [__] even
good enough do you have fun do you care
it was just all of those sorts of things
piling on top of me and um I paused
filming I think I flew to LA and uh I
had the two days with you guys to do to
do the minor and I was [__] cracking
up yeah you so happy yeah back to like
and I I was like no you do love it you
just gota you know just gotta be a
minutor yeah but like no it was it was
the kind of it was the kind of
realization I needed at that moment I
was like don't let you know being you
know and it's normal I'm not you know if
if you work a lot and you guys know this
we all do like you're not going to love
everything you do you're just you're not
it's not possible some projects for me
aren't passion projects sometimes
they're convenient or they keep me in
Los Angeles list in general you know I
just got to do this pay the
bells yeah right it's pretty it's pretty
uh it's pretty just grind grind nose to
the grindstone grind every week
playwatch listen out every Friday never
miss but yeah like it we're pretty Pro
crunch
culture but yeah it was uh yeah anyway
it was one of it was one of them ones it
just snuck up on me I didn't realize I
was like oh dude you love this don't you
know don't um I had the best time and
then you know once the song came out and
the reception and I'm so happy I did it
um so yeah you hear that
key yeah Jeff we're mates as well should
I to do with him shall I tell him I'm
not presenting any Awards this year yeah
just text him and say that he
like I can I bring up one last thing it
just has to be quick because we're about
to get real noisy okay uh also I'm super
excited for for Andy and Taylor's
project which has been publicly
announced right yeah yeah yes yes yes
X-Men yes yeah yeah yeah I cannot wait I
am so excited like oh Sor I was gonna
mute that I remember I have another
person here I'm so used to muing when I
sneak sorry but um but yeah I know you
probably can't talk anything about it
but I every time we're together I want
you to play me stuff but we're psyched
yeah we're super pumped yeah it's it's
it's coming soon it's coming very soon
oh sweet yeah uh Andy where can people
find you in Taylor if they want to find
more of your work um we're on all the
we're on Spotify and apple music and
YouTube and then we're on uh inag and
Twitter and it's it's just under the
Newton Brothers um all of our triplets
triplets triplets as will be that's
right and and given that this is
ostensibly hypothetically a video game
podcast we can wrap it all up by also
offering congrats to the two of you for
Five Nights at Freddy's uh film
adaptation crushing it intern crushing
it period I start to say internationally
but it's just been a massive box office
probably probably one of blue Mouse's
bigger hits I would think yeah it's done
I I I think I think it might be one of
their bigger yeah one of their biggest
sort of uh releases like multiple
hundreds of millions box office level
hit huge property so you had Usher and
five nights come out in the space of
like same two weeks and technically you
w allow to talk about either of them for
a minute yeah yeah it was like real just
keeping it all real yeah it was kind of
a Usher Usher and Five Nights at
Freddy's but can't really celebrate too
busy working on
X-Men what a life Andy not bad [__]
slacker yeah R where can people find you
oh uh Instagram um Roy COI 13 it's not
particularly
interesting no that's not true what
we've found is is if we respond uh in uh
slightly provocative manners you'll
screenshot it and offer
great way to get attention there yeah
but I do it because it disappears after
24 hours and I and um for me it feels
like it's not the Internet isn't forever
so I'm happy to just um be a prick in my
stories but I'm very professional on my
permanent
feed that's where you'll see nice behind
the scenes stuff just in the stories you
calling people a [__] yeah pretty much
yeah
discrepancy you have to know that Taylor
and I talk your posts and are so good we
love like you're just yeah what you're
doing on social media Taylor and I talk
about it all the time Taylor will call
me up we'll be talking about like you
see what Rahul posted
like yeah that's apparently I got told
when we were do BL it was a bit of a
shock for Trevor and Mike because I'm
not I'm not crazy on like in when I work
I'm super quiet and respectful I don't
bounce off the walls but then in my
pocket in the green room I look I'm like
arranged on social
media and um I posted on Mike's I didn't
even know Mike that well but I
photoshopped you know dem me more
Patrick sey the pottery thing I had put
our faces on it and posted it as like to
celebrate us collaborating on Blye and I
didn't even earn that and and he and I
was like you know some because it was
Ghost related or spooky and I remember
them going oh Trevor's being like that's
an interesting that's an interesting
thing to do that's uh that's cool um and
uh yeah I got super self-conscious about
that thought about it for six weeks keep
it up yeah um about to get very noisy
here the the first practice lap is a
matter of minutes away gonna get is it
outside your window is it out window or
near it's nearby I guess super nearby we
have padic passes which I don't they
look amazing yeah so these are crazy I I
I bought tickets for F1 for R's birthday
and because I've been a Motorsports fan
for forever um and then I messaged EA
and was like hey by the way I'm going to
the F1 if you need anyone to do anything
and in exchange for doing some stuff
with we told them I was Grammy
nominated we got these beautiful passes
that like come in these
like oh contain boxes like they're the
the best liion look like
phone and there's one each day so
they're all like different colors um and
these are padic paes which they're worth
like 20 grams like it's it's absolutely
gosh yeah so these are like solid steel
yeah uh thank very thankful for it so
yeah the padic is basically like I guess
the ideal place to go um I'm just super
excited I'm so so happy to be here are
you going to the sphere in the meantime
we think we will go to the spere to yeah
we we went to the garages we can say
that right that was yeah we went to the
like actual wild just seeing team
Ferrari yeah it's super it's very very
cool to be here it's super exciting but
it's also a disaster because the strip
is all closed but it's crazy when you're
like when we got a cab like you're on
the track right now right because all of
the the barriers are up so you're you're
because it's still for the for the
general public during the day yeah which
is like a really shitty thing about it
actually is you know they have all the
sky bridges in Vegas they've put up
barriers to stop people from watching
the Races they put up this like so you
can't just stand on those and watch yeah
they they were they were clear and now
they've put on these like stickers to
make them distorted so people can't
Spectators which I think such a [__]
thing to do yeah like you're in that
City let him
watch where do you can see from sidewalk
though no that's too dangerous you could
probably see I think that they're like
they've built them back a little bit but
not too much there are gonna be people
everywhere wow but it looks so like we
were in the course today right in the
cab it looks so narrow yeah it's nuts
and they're going to be going there at
200 miles hour but it's the most amazing
birthday present like I only found out
like a few days ago she' kept it a
secret and um yeah and she'd been like
doing things where I was being scheduled
for work and I'd go yeah I can do that
date but she knew I couldn't because I
we were going to be in Vegas so she was
going behind my back yeah I had to email
his manager she contact my manager be
like he's not available for that date
scripts I had both their emails and I
had to be like he's not available that
dat please don't tell him why and then
they'd come back and go sorry had to
reschedule and I'd be like that's
[__] unacceptable how stop mucking me
around not knowing that
they we were gonna have you uh audition
for Nolan but I guess you're too busy uh
F1 busy at Vegas nice work yes yeah
anytime uh on that note thank you for
joining us we could have spoken about
this for way longer I'm sure I still
have so much Usher stuff I want to talk
about I want to visit Andy Studio we've
been saying it for ages come over
anytime group P anytime you got like a
cool bar don't you I have a great bar
here there's a great bar here we could
yeah we should let's get Austin there's
three of us let's go in any case thank
you all so much for watching I'm Al
that's Rahul that's
Austin that's Andy there's Austin right
here there's Austin this is play watch
listen we'll see you next time bye bye
sorry about the audio